I've talked to you before about the town
of Kennesaw Georgia which is sort of
known in gun fetishist circles because
they quote require gun ownership and
once again in the wake of the parkland
Florida shooting you've got
conservatives and you've got Breitbart
they're all talking about just how safe
Kennesaw Georgia is because of their
mandatory gun law and I want to take a
few minutes to completely debunk the
bogus nonsense that they're spreading
here and just as an example Breitbart
recently touted just how safe it is
there they had an article where they say
CNN admits us town where guns are
required has had only one murder in six
years and there are sort of a few
different misleading claims here one of
the claims that's misleading is about
the law itself and then the other
relates to the sort of noteworthy nature
of the data that they present so first
let's talk about the law the law is not
enforced right this is a law that's been
around in Kennesaw Georgia since 1982
and it's not really enforced the law
says that every head of household in the
city limits has to maintain a firearm as
well as ammunition but if you have a
physical or mental disability you are
exempt from the law if you can't afford
a gun you are exempt from the law if you
are federally prohibited from owning a
gun you are exempt from the law and if
you simply don't want a gun you are also
exempt from the law so the law firm
mandatory gun ownership doesn't actually
require mandatory gun ownership that's
number one right so so right away any of
these claims are ridiculous but let's
for a second pretend that it's true
let's pretend it's mandatory let's
pretend everybody has guns which they
don't and net let's now evaluate the
safety of the of the town one murder in
six years right Kennesaw Georgia has a
population of about thirty three
thousand people according to the census
recent local census of 2016 and they had
one murder in the last six years and
this reminded me because of the
population of the starting place of the
David Pakman show
Northampton Massachusetts which has a
similar population it's a small city of
29,000 people and I went back and I
looked at the crime data and Northampton
has had zero murders in the last seven
years
Northampton has no mandatory gun law and
in fact it's in Massachusetts meaning
that it's on the sort of stricter end of
gun safety legislation so why is it
notable that Kennesaw Georgia had one
murder in six years
when Northampton Massachusetts has no
mandatory gun law and has had no murders
for the last seven years now the truth
of the story is that these numbers are
just too small to really mean anything
right any fundamental basic
understanding of statistics tells us
that one murder in six years in a town
of thirty three thousand and zero
murders in seven years in a town of
twenty nine thousand it's just not
enough data to tell us anything one way
or the other but what's crystal clear is
that the right wing story about Kennesaw
Georgia being number one super safe
because of number two the notion that
there's mandatory and total gun
ownership could not be further from the
truth I think I use that one correctly
yes I did send me your thoughts that
Kennesaw Georgia story is so bogus and
it's sad that the right that the gun
fetishists even talk about it I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show
today's program is made possible in part
by futur vittor is a social forecasting
game where you compete with other
players to predict the future and it's
built on the principles of what's called
a prediction market a scientifically
proven way of using the wisdom of the
crowd to create more accurate
predictions about future events
prediction markets have been shown to
work much better than other forecasting
methods like polling or expert analysis
in many cases and futur has actually
taken the concept and turned it into a
fun easy to use social game you open up
the futur app and you'll see a whole
range of forecasts covering topics
across the board from politics to sports
and everything in between you can
check out my predictions and follow me
to get updates on my profile which is
linked to in the description if you're
watching this on YouTube the tour is a
great tool to find out more about the
world improve your forecasting ability
show off your prediction skills to
friends and even better when you make
predictions on futur you're helping to
create more accurate forecasts for
everybody their mission of creating
better predictions is great and actually
going in there and seeing how well you
can do at predicting the future can be
kind of addicting go to futur com sign
up and start making forecast it's free
and it's available on both Android and
iOS as well as on web browsers and
that's f you t you you are calm